how's it going my name is Onew day today
we're making beef stew
the nyjah way I cannot remember the
first time I had an injury and beef stew
because it's been a part of my life
forever yeah
like most people growing up you know
they got to get McDonald's and stuff
like that that was not the case in an
Indian household at all I'm one of five
and sometimes my mom was like you know
she don't feel like giving us individual
plates so the great thing that she used
to do which I found so funny is she used
to put it in like this really really big
bowl think family-style and give us all
a spoon and walk away and then at that
point it was like free-for-all my mom
made it makes it different you know what
she added like you know shucky and all
these other beef parts and it's
delicious but you know there's a basic
way to make it you can just have the
basic beef part and that's enough just
different ways you can do it but at the
end of the day it's all delicious and
you know everyone can agree on good food
it's almost like the Romans like
crawling out of the pot and it's just a
lovely smell you can bring someone you
know from down the street with the smell
inside it's a great great aroma you want
to eat it before it's even done my
favorite part of the dish absolutely has
to be when you're just trying to get
every piece on the spoon like you're
trying to get the rice with the stew and
the beef and then if you're lucky you
can get a little plants and on there as
well just it's a mouthful of just
happiness
how often do you get that opportunity to
have such a diverse culinary experience
in 20 minutes bike in 20 minutes this is
your one-way ticket to Africa come join
us in and Ariens and eating this
delicious beef stew we invite you and we
hope you enjoy the list you know oh oh
yes